at least four people have been killed
and dozens more injured injured in
wildfires
in southern turkey the blazes threatened
popular beach resorts including several
in the antalya
region across the mediterranean coast
authorities suspect
arsonists have started at least some of
the fires
temperatures approaching 40 degrees
celsius
and strong winds are spreading the fires
many neighborhoods were evacuated as
flames engulfed homes
and vehicles
i lost everything my car has burnt i
couldn't save anything
the fire broke out very quickly we had
to flee and this is what we came back to
authorities are investigating what
started the blazes
some suspect arson because four fires
broke out in different places
at the same time huge plumes of smoke
can be seen in popular resorts
along the coast including madmaris and
boardroom
hundreds of tourists have been evacuated
from their hotels
president erdogan says everything
possible is being done
my name is oki we hope to put out these
fires without any casualties
the fires have spread across a wide area
and we hope to put them out as soon as
possible
everything will be investigated and we
will support our citizens who are
suffering
[Music]
the wildfires have consumed livestock as
well
and injured domestic pets
thousands of firefighters are working in
extreme
heat to contain the flames but
authorities are warning that the
operation
is likely to take some time
and more families may need to flee to
safety
i'm now joined by uh our correspondent
in istanbul julia han julia
give us an update what's the situation
this morning
well first of all let me say the images
we've been getting from south and turkey
are
apocalyptic and heart-wrenching
firefighters are still struggling to get
some of the blazers under control
according to the authorities there have
been more than 60 separate fires in
different parts of the country most of
them in the south
in recent days some of them as you
mentioned
in popular mediterranean resort regions
now while the authorities say most of
the fires are now under control
others are still raging on turkey's
minister of forestry last night said on
twitter that the whole nation
quote was fighting a war right now we
are
burning he wrote but we will extinguish
the fire now several people have been
reported dead more than 180 were sent to
hospitals
with burns and smoke poisoning and many
others have lost
everything we spoke to farmers in the
southern turkish district of
manafkat let's listen to what they had
to say
some of the animals burned where they
were some were released but they burned
in the forest
these are the ones left we had around 40
sheep and goats
we lost all of them the fire came all of
a sudden it turned everything into ashes
we barely saved our lives the children
went one way we went the other
everyone tried to escape it's
devastating absolutely
julia devastating fire is destroying
people's livelihoods there and we also
saw huge plumes of smoke behind rising
up behind
beaches how close are the fires to
popular tourist resorts right now
well they have been very close to some
of the tourist spots there at the
mediterranean and the asian
coast popular with local tourists but
also with vacationers from russia from
the uk
and from germany yesterday the flames
have crept closer to the sandy beaches
and hotels of towns like
manafghad marmarus and bodrum several
hotels had to be evacuated
now this is very devastating for all
those who work in tourism in the region
region the tourism sector has lost
nearly
70 percent in revenues last year due
to the covert 19 pandemic because
foreign tourists the the number of
foreign tourists
who arrived in turkey dropped
dramatically now
this time many had hoped for a recovery
for a slightly better season
and now the wildfires they are
threatening lives they are threatening
property so for many people there in the
region
what's at stake is their very existence
and we also just heard that the fires
might be a result of arson what are the
authorities saying
well let me mention that wildfires are
not on
uncommon in south and turkey especially
in summer it's very hot there the fires
are raging with temperatures from 35 to
40 degrees celsius there are strong
winds and this is what experts have been
citing why
the fires are spreading and why it's so
difficult to
put them out now they're also
often citing climate change as a
contributing factor here but yes
uh the authorities among them entires
mayor have
said they suspected foul play because
in entire province fires broke out in
four
locations at the same time so an
investigation
has been launched into arson suspicions
but nothing has emerged from that yet
uw's julia hahn in istanbul there thank
you very much julia